Investing in single founders is
something that most investors don't like
to do.
They're used to investing in
teams of two's, or three, or
more because they believe that you
need multiple skills, market and
complementary skill set in order to
drive an early stage startup forward.
There are exceptions of course, and
it happens more than once or twice.
But for the large part, my big advice
I like to give entrepreneurs is find
a co-founder that you want
to go to war with, right,
that you want to actually do this
impossible thing called a startup.
Someone that compliments you,
that you really want to go with for
multiple years to come.